[Musique]
bien sûr les meilleurs pays pour être
mère selon les plus récentes données
publiées en 2015 par les ong britannique
save the children
les pays scandinaves sont en tête de
liste encore une fois la norvège serait
le pays le plus avantageux pour les
mamans suivi par la finlande l'islande
le danemark et la suède
parmi les critères de classement on
retrouve le taux de mortalité maternelle
et infantile le salaire moyen annuel et
les années de scolarisation des cours
prénataux gratuit les congés parentaux
généreux et des garderies très abordable
favorise également les mamans
scandinaves et le canada dans ce
palmarès mondial
il se trouvait au 20e rang sur 179 pays
soulignons toutefois que les mères
québécoises bénéficie des meilleures
congés parentaux au pays depuis
l'instauration du régime québécois
d'assurance parentale en 2006
save the children publié en 2016 l'étude
evry largo sur la situation des filles
dans le monde selon des critères comme
les grossesses et les mariages précoces
le niveau d'éducation les trois
meilleurs pays pour l'épanouissement des
fillettes sont la suède la finlande et
la norvège le canada lui occupe la 19ème
position dans cette catégorie